welcome to this video yeah I am I am
never had Xavier Mourinho Lewis Madrid
Spain okie dokie mmm so on let's do this
again nowadays most people play the ship
t2m or this at Bishop g2 with them when
the justification of course it's the
best line yeah you for in this position
I think I can play I'm sorry d5 this
position I think I can go a form i have
looked at that line but not entirely
sure i think i can go in for here in
this position let's try that of course i
can't even I'd be eight but I think here
this is some more of an idea compared to
the position position without age 6 okay
so 94 is this a good move now and I've
got this trick here Jay that's a pretty
embarrassing move to face of him
white yes it's funny huh he takes he
takes loses the Queen and he has to move
the King I which is a complete disaster
Kingdom group g1 I mean he just lost the
bonnet the position is just pretty
terrible Bishop en then c5 is probably
easiest yeah so this is an interesting
variation but gee I think he has to move
the nightie I think not 92 when you move
the night but to d2 I think after which
i'm going is free this is the point
heavy blankets just dropping that pawn
and then gets to e5 with a night not
going back to be aid it's an interesting
idea if this happens here I can take
possibly night before I said a move not
quite sure something like this should be
okay for me yeah until he went here 19 5
and now he probably I don't know he has
to play baby Bishop g2 or something so
that's after the check he can go King f1
which makes this check rather
unattractive in comparison but I can
take the spawn of course I think yes to
do it this is check losing straight away
funny tactic ok well thanks for watching